avant l'été 2010
qu'est ce que personne dans la petite
ville tranquille de manche au michigan
nous connaissaient enbridge et gaz 80%
des gens d'ici mars ne savais pas qu'il
y avait un pipeline
j'ignorais complètement qu'il
transportait du pétrole des sables
bitumineux
enbridge possède le réseau de pikine le
plus étendu au monde 26 mille kilomètres
de conduite qui s'étendent jusqu'au
québec resam comme le pipeline personne
ne s'intéressait le 25 juillet 2010 les
gens de manchots ont appris son
existence de la pire manière qui soit la
conduite numéro 6 a laissé échapper près
de trois millions et demi de litres de
pétrole brut dans l'environnement
l'accident a révélé des lacunes
insoupçonnée dans la sécurité et
l'entretien du pipeline veille ils ont
développé une culture de déviance et
c'est devenu la norme
un tel accident pourrait-il se produire
ici au québec ça pourrait produire
n'importe où
[Musique]
il est 17 heures 58 quand le premier
signe d'un problème dans la conduite
numéro 6 apparaît 3000 kilomètres plus
loin sur un écran du centre de contrôle
d'un bridge est maintenu
salut
la masse bm sur la conductrice bravo
tronçon de à marchaux stoppé une dizaine
d'armes se succèdent qui indique une
fuite mais pas une seconde on envisage
ce scénario nous avons obtenu du bureau
américain de la sécurité des transports
la transcription des communications au
centre de contrôle
cette reconstitution en est la
traduction exacte une séparation des
flux qui causent la lampe à maurice pons
c'est ça la rigueur à finir aucune
pression dans la conduite
ils ont prévu mais il s'agissait d'une
séparation des flux
c'est comme une grosse bulle d'air dans
le pipeline
sauf que 5 rue survenir dans ce type de
géographie à mort sur les dans les
environs une odeur âcre et sulfureuse se
répand c'est difficile à décrire et à
s'imaginer du bitume et du goudron et de
l'essence est de seulement un vernis à
ongle mélanger ensemble
[Musique]
avec la violence d'un coup de couteau
walker
en soirée le 9 1 1 reçoit plusieurs
appels de citoyens qui les pompiers
envoyés sur les dieux confirmé l'odeur
mais notre pas la source dans la nuit
puis à nouveau au matin les contrôleurs
enfreignent la procédure il redémarre le
pipeline malgré les anars me répéter il
ya eu trois quarts de travail
le problème s'est répété chaque fois
détail important les employés ont été
mises en doute que quelque chose
n'allait pas mais personne ne les a
écoutés on a du mal à remettre les flux
ensemble à man show on a besoin d'un peu
plus de jus est-ce qu'on peut augmenter
le volume à la porte
à chaque redémarrage
on injecte du pétrole dans le pipeline
je peux augmenter la pression dangereux
mais je risque pas dépassé la limite
d'âge de plein oui mais c'est normal
le pétrole doit bien aller quelque part
pendant l'opération
les contrôleurs pompe deux millions et
demi de litres de pétrole
ignorant qu'il se déversent directement
dans la nature de ce second nous semble
que quelque chose ne tourner pas rond
ouais les contrôleurs continue d'ignorer
tous les indices qui pointent vers une
suite
pep à la journée finie on sera en congé
par mois quel jour exactement on va
arrêter de s'en faire avec ça quant aux
raisons j'arrête de m'en faire et ils
ont vraiment ces sites se fier à leur
donner
certains ont même dit bien s'il ya une
fuite ou quelqu'un va nous appeler pour
multi
et c'est ce qui va se produire c'est par
un appel du public sur sa ligne
d'urgence kennebec j'apprends la rupture
de son pipeline
[Musique]
17 heures se sont écoulées depuis la
première à l'ars
[Musique]
la fuite est une des pires jamais
survenus aux états unis
[Musique]
le pétrole va contaminer l'écosystème
délicat de la rivière kalamazoo sur 60
km le taux élevé de benzène dans l'air
force l'évacuation d'une cinquantaine de
familles
on rentrait à la maison vers 18 heures
et plus on approchait du barrage
plus on sentait une terrible odeur les
fenêtres de la maison étaient fermés
mais l'odeur avaient tous un prêt ni à
l'intérieur
en moins d'une demi-heure le nez couler
les yeux brûlés 2008 ces risques ou le
premier village en aval droite et ce
droit
l'eau était noir n'a et je n'exagère pas
l'eau du barrage était littéralement
noir ça déclenche une graine instantané
michel daerden smit vita bâton quick
c'est elle qui a alerté les médias
nationaux en mettant ses photos sur le
web
j'ai toujours fait de la photo et le
temps qu'on comprenne ce qui se passe
les équipes de nettoyage avait déjà
déployé leurs équipements nous sommes
excusés les désagréments et des dégâts
que nous avons connues malgré les
excuses
les premiers efforts d'un bridge sur le
terrain sont durement critiqué le plan
d'urgence de la compagnie est inadéquat
à mon avis ces efforts sont insuffisants
[Musique]
aurait pu empêcher une bonne partition
la totalité du pétrole d'atteindre la
rivière kalamazoo en ayant recours à des
techniques simples et éprouvé dès le
premier jour le personnel était mal
formés il n'avait pas l'équipement
nécessaire
[Musique]
devant l'ampleur des dégâts
enbridge doit faire face à la colère et
l'inquiétude des risques je suis une
survivante
j'ai survécu à ça c'est la première fois
que michel bernines smet revient à
battle creek depuis qu'elle a abandonné
sa maison son ancien quartier est
déserté 80 familles et ville est ici
avant des versements il n'en reste
qu'une vingtaine un petit mtv de vide ça
serait plus simple vous indiquer ce qui
reste
la plupart des résidents n'ont pas pu
bénéficier du programme d'achat de
maisons offertes par enbridge a racheté
des maisons de 200 mille dollars un peu
plus loin parce que les propriétaires
avaient sans doute les moyens de se
payer des avocats réputés
ici ils nous ont simplement laissé
tomber c'était décourageant
il n'y avait rien à faire et personne ne
pouvait nous dire les risques pour la
santé
christine deux se dit avoir éprouvé des
symptômes respiratoires la santé
publique a recensé plus de 300 personnes
affectées par l'exposition aux valeurs
du pétrole lourd
j'ai fait plusieurs visites à l'hôpital
beaucoup de gens ont été très malade
enbridge a tout de même distribué des
purificateurs d'air mais il était
inutile contre les types de contaminants
chimiques auxquels les résidents étaient
exposés de certains sont fait offrir un
purificateur d'air et un film en
contrepartie il fallait signer un
document
les gens ne se rendait pas compte qu'en
signant il dégageait enbridge de toute
responsabilité
enbridge a corrigé la situation des
résidents ont entrepris une poursuite
bien qu'il soit difficile d'établir un
lien direct entre leurs problèmes de
santé chroniques et le déversement pour
des bleus
une survivante du cancer liquide se dé
justifié je suis terrifiée
il n'y a jamais eu d'études sur des
effets à long terme sur la santé humaine
d'une exposition au bitume diluée on ne
sait vraiment pas ce qui nous attend
le pétrole des sables bitumineux de
l'alberta est un des produits cambridge
compte transporter dans le guêpier 9 b
qui traverse l'ontario et le québec
jusqu'à montréal
les opposants au projet qui craignent
une répétition de la catastrophe
survenue aux états unis n'ont pas tort
de soulever la question
ça aurait pu survenir n'importe où notre
réseau d'un voyage parce qu'elle s'était
trompée dans son analyse des risques aux
sports c'est la découverte la plus
troublante du rapport des autorités
américaines
des saignées annoncé la catastrophe au
michigan
enbridge ne les a pas vus
[Musique]
en dessous de ses champs de maïs se
trouve le pipeline 9 bainbridges
c'est ici qu'il entre au québec par la
petite municipalité rurale de
sainte-justine-de-newton en cas de
déversement
il faut prévoir jusqu'à 4 heures pour
accéder à cette valve manuel au fond du
septième rang si la fuite est petit ça
peut peut-être n'avoir que des
conséquences minimes
si la fuite et grosse caisse qui
arrivera le projet d'inversion du flux
du pipeline fait jaser tout le monde
estime justin même pendant la course
annuelle de tracteurs
une occasion pour la mairesse d'échangés
et l'excès citoyens si on a un
déversement à sainte-justine là on peut
fermer toutes nos maisons tout
ici on craint qu'un déversement
contamine les terres agricoles et
l'approvisionnement en eau potable à des
kilomètres à la ronde
mes inquiétudes somptueux 'pipeline' à
38 ans c'est un vieux park lane et on
veut lui faire passer dedans du pétrole
extrait des sables bitumineux en
quantité plus importante puisque on
passerait de 240000 barré à 300000 barré
joue
[Musique]
au québec le pipeline traverse des cours
d'eau important pour nos potable et des
zones densément peuplées
il passe en dessous des cours arrière à
terrebonne laval rivière des prairies
nous avons pu l'approcher à mirabel des
travaux d'excavation sont en cours pour
respecter et aux besoins réparer des
anomalies décelées lors d'inspections
interne sur la corrosion interne externe
soit au niveau de bosses au niveau de
fissures permet maintenant d'aller
exactement l'endroit où cette anomalie a
été localisé il y aura une centaine de
ces fouilles
rien qu'à mirabel au moins six ans
peut-être davantage pour l'ensemble de
la conduite entre montréal et ouest
ouvre mais and bridges se fait rassurant
et si on comparait six ans que tout est
en très bonne condition pour son âge
on est dans la majeure partie de la
ligne 9 sur le bouclier canadien et qui
fait qu'au niveau d'infiltration d'eau
qu'il ya un risque au niveau de la
corrosion
ça diminue le risque ici
sur le chantier on n'a toutefois pas
aimé qu'on s'attarde à cette anomalie
visible transporteurs excuser ces fonds
des vérifications
même s'ils font l'entretien ces vieux ya
rien qui dit que d'un seul coup ça va
pas brisée puis faire comme à calama
roue puis qu'on ait un déversement
majeur la conduite ne vais à plusieurs
éléments communs des classe 6d au
michigan
elles ont été construites autour des
années soixante dix c'est le même type
d'acier même type de soudure même dit à
m et le même revêtement de polyéthylène
qui peut exposer le pipeline à la
corrosion
c'est justement un mélange de corrosion
et de fissures qui a causé la rupture au
michigan des problèmes qu'aucun indice
ne permettait de soupçonner
selon wayne bridge anglais du prorata je
suis content qu'il ait soulevé la
question
les données de la dernière inspection
produite par notre fournisseur
n'indiquait aucun problème aux marchands
mais enbridge connaissait les faiblesses
du pipeline depuis au moins cinq ans
affirme le bureau américain de la
sécurité des transports était au courant
de la corrosion ainsi que des fissures
le problème c'est qu'ils ne les ont pas
considérer ensemble
mais ces deux mécanismes de dégradation
combinés ont affaibli le pipeline et
causé sa rupture
d'ailleurs par mesure de précaution le
pipeline fonctionner à pression réduite
or tout de suite après le déversement de
kalamazoo enbridge a aussi réduit la
pression dans son pipeline 9 et chez
nous
une réduction pression est mise en place
lorsqu'une inspections révèlent des
faiblesses afin de réduire les risques
les dernières inspections au québec et
en ontario vieille d'environ 5 ans
révélée 4738 anomalies de degrés
variables relié à la formation de
fissures et 8223 à la corrosion 25 de
ces anomalies atteindront un seuil
critique d'ici décembre 2013
enbridge je reconnais qu'une nouvelle
inspection faite récemment a révélé un
nombre accru d'anomalie
elle n'a pas divulgué ces résultats
[Musique]
le slogan la rivière kalamazoo était
ouverte au public en 2012
il a fallu deux ans de travaux de
dragage et de reconstruction enbridge
pour honorer sa promesse faite aux
résidents il avait promis d'ouvrir la
rivière quand elle serait sécuritaire
malheureusement le pdg jeff bridges a
pris sa retraite et il a sûrement
l'occasion d'aller à la pêche bien loin
d'ici alors que nous on est devant
l'inconnu car sous son nom limpide se
cachent encore 700 mhz et litres
d'hydrocarbures englué dans les
sédiments
le résultat des erreurs commises aux
premières heures certains endroits ça a
été bien fait alors qu'à d'autres ça a
été mal fait oui ça ça nous poursuit si
la responsabilité d'anne bridge c'est ce
qui explique la présence encore
aujourd'hui la situation a forcé m
brutes le mois dernier à refermer
partiellement la rivière et reprendre le
nettoyage
enbridge considère que le pétrole des
sables bitumineux n'est pas plus
difficile à nettoyer n'est plus
dangereux pour l'environnement qu'une
brut conventionnel
je ne comprends pas comment il
ce n'est pas l'avis de steven hamilton
un biologiste qui étudient cette rivière
depuis des années une fois séparé de ses
diluant dit il le bitume est
problématique
le bitume reprend sa consistance
visqueuse et devient collant bien deux
il n'y a aucun doute si ce produit s'est
enfoncé ici alors que la rivière n'a
rien de spécial il s'enfoncera dans
d'autres rivières
la facture du nettoyage atteint le
milliard de dollars un milliard c'est
presque la somme qu'ils brûlent investi
cette année en amélioration pour assurer
l'intégrité de son réseau assure qu'il
ira chez enbridge la volonté de ne plus
jamais revivre
l'instant qui s'est passé à man show
alors tout ce qui est possible de faire
afin de pouvoir prévenir et prise en
considération
mais les autorités américaines restent
prudentes nous avons noté les
changements qu'ils ont bien joué c'est
évident que si nous avions été
satisfaits nous n'aurions pas émis une
recommandation qui mettent leur culotte
je dirais
patricia domingo veut que le fils
national de l'énergie exigent plus de
garanties avant d'autoriser l'inversion
du pipeline qui traverse son territoire
on a demandé un fonds de prévoyance qui
seraient prêts à la même à l'inversion
parce qu'on sait que cala maso c'est un
milliard déjà
donc est ce qu'il y aura un déversement
deux déversements 3 déversement donc il
faudrait que déjà ce milliard soit là la
municipalité suggère des pénalités plus
sévères en cas de manquement aux normes
117 des 125 station de pompage du réseau
d'un bridge ne sont pas conformes en ce
moment la compagnie s'attend à ce que le
projet d'inversion soit accordée elle
compte même se prévaloir d'une exemption
à la loi pour procéder avant même que le
fils national de l'énergie est rendu sa
décision au michigan des bleus à ce
message pour les canadiens je suis
frustré envers enbridge et je suis
frustré envers mon gouvernement pour
avoir permis que les profits passe avant
la sécurité
j'espère que le canada fera mieux